a return to an apocalyptic demolition
derby wasteland another adventure inside
a deadly neon video game and the
revisitation of a halloween classic all
this and more await you with these movie
sequels you may not have heard about the
first predator filmed tore into theaters
in 1987 launching a whole franchise that
has endured across decades and now
almost inevitably a fifth film is on the
horizon the most recent installment
2018's the predator was hardly a
critical success currently sitting at a
dismal 33 on round tomatoes but it still
made enough money at the box office to
justify yet another sequel never knew
how much i missed this dutch
you never were that smart
predator 5 will be helmed by 10
cloverfield lane director dan
trachtenberg from a script pen by
budding screenwriter patrick asim
originally the fifth predator film was
announced under the title skulls but the
official title has since been confirmed
as prey each predator installment thus
far has focused on a group of people
being hunted by a race of alien trophy
hunters and prey seems like it will
follow in that same tradition this time
the story will be set 300 years in the
past and center on the comanche nation
following a warrior named nauru who will
be played by amber mitthunder while the
fifth predator seemed to hit an
unforeseen snag in the form of a lawsuit
filed by the original film's writers jim
and john thomas that apparently didn't
stop the movie from moving forward prey
wrapped filming in september 2021 and is
set to premiere on hulu sometime in
summer 2022
while hocus pocus failed to make much of
a splash when it was first released in
1993 it has since gathered a significant
following as a halloween staple the film
follows a group of kids who accidentally
resurrect a trio of witches on halloween
300 years after their execution the
sisters set about stealing the souls of
every child in salem unless these
intrepid heroes can stop them while
details on the sequel film remain scarce
original hocus pocus stars bette midler
cathy the jimmy and sarah jessica parker
are set to return in the sequel which
will debut on disney plus in the fall of
2022 some of the movies most notable
cast members include doug jones
reprising his role from the original as
well as tony hale hannah waddingham and
sam richardson working from a script by
jen d'angelo hocus pocus 2 was
originally said to be directed by adam
shankman but he was replaced in 2021 by
comedy stalwart and fletcher according
to an official synopsis for the film
hocus pocus ii will follow three young
women as they bring the sanderson
sisters back to modern day salem forcing
them to stop the three witches from
wreaking havoc in the modern world
before john boyega was known for
battling the first order in star wars he
was fighting unsettling monstrous aliens
in the urban sci-fi adventure attack the
block written and directed by joe
cornish the 2011 film starred boyega as
moses the leader of a teenage street
gang that must rid their neighborhood of
invading extraterrestrials the sequel
will reunite boyega and cornish who's
once again both writing and directing
this time boyega will also be acting as
co-producer in addition to reprising his
role as moses speaking to deadline
voyega said it's been a decade since
attack the block was released and so
much has changed since then i'm excited
to see this heightened story return to
the streets of london moses has remained
one of my favorite characters to play
and bringing him back is a huge honor
cornish echoed his enthusiasm saying i'm
thrilled we're officially announcing our
return to the world of attack the block
on the 10th anniversary of the film's
release i can't wait to work alongside
john again bringing audiences an even
bigger slice of inner city alien action
according to cornish filming on attack
the block 2 is expected to start at some
point in 2022 indicating that the movie
might premiere as early as 2023
within days of the simultaneous
theatrical and hbo max release of dune a
sequel was officially greenlit with a
release date set for october 20th 2023.
the decision to produce dune part 2
won't come as a shock to anyone who
knows the novel or saw the first film
which ended in what seemed to be a
pretty pivotal moment in the character
arc of protagonist paula tradies dune
began a sprawling tale of feuding
households political maneuvering and
religious intrigue told through an
impressive ensemble cast led by timothy
chalamet of course not all the central
players in dunes survived until the end
but those that did are expected to
reprise the rules in the sequel it's
also a given that zendaya whose
character is only introduced toward the
tail end of the original will be playing
a much bigger role in this installment
also returning art director denis
villeneuve and composer han zimmer the
latter of whom recently joked in a tweet
thank goodness i have some music left as
for vilnev the director clarified that
he considers dune part 2 the same movie
as dune rather than a traditional sequel
telling the hollywood reporter it's not
a sequel where it's another episode or
another story with the same characters
it actually has direct continuity to the
first movie it's the second part of the
big huge movie that i'm trying to do
unlike the original part 2 will not
debut on hbo max instead receiving an
exclusive 45-day theatrical window
apparently this was a non-negotiable
point for vilnov who says that for him
the theatrical experience is at the very
heart of the cinematic language oh what
a day
what a lovely day
in 2015 mad max fury road reinvigorated
the long dormant mad max franchise which
began in 1979 with mel gibson in the
title role fury road offered a new spin
on the post-apocalyptic tale casting tom
hardy as max and shifting focus to
charlize theron's rage fueled imperator
furiosa fury road also wowed audiences
and critics alike with many considering
it one of the best action films of all
time a sequel then seemed inevitable
sure enough two follow-up films are in
the works one is a direct sequel while
the other is a prequel centered around a
younger furiosa the sequel which has
been given the working title mad max the
wasteland was reportedly greenlit by
warner brothers in early 2020 and will
follow hardy's max rokitansky meanwhile
furiosa will bring back the title
character in question though theron
won't be making an appearance in the
movie director george miller has said
that much as he loved theron's
performance in fury road he doesn't have
enough faith in the aging technology to
allow theron to reprise her role for the
prequel instead the younger furiosa will
be played by anya taylor joy who will be
joined by mcu star chris hemsworth
emmy-winning watchman actor yaya
abdulmatin ii was also set to star on
the sequel but later departed the
project due to scheduling conflicts
instead tom burke will be stepping into
the role originally intended for abdul
mateen miller hasn't yet revealed who
hemsworth and burke will be playing in
furiosa but the characters have likely
existed in the director's head since
before the previous film as he and
co-writer nick lathurus developed origin
stories for every character while
prepping fury road the wasteland is set
to release on june 23 2023 while furiosa
will tear into theaters on may 27 2024
the star trek franchise has been a
shining gem in paramount's crown for
decades and there are a number of
directors the popular franchise could
head next moving forward right now is a
fourth star trek film in the current
series which would bring back the cast
of 2009 star trek and its sequels minus
anton yelchin who was tragically killed
in an accident in 2016. the studio is
also considering trek films from the
revenant scribe mark l smith which was
originally intended to be directed by
quentin tarantino as well as one from
fargo and legion creator noah holly
while holly's project has been moved to
the back burner by paramount star trek
iv is reportedly full steam ahead one
division director matt shakman has
signed on to helm the project working
off a script from lindsay beer and
geneva robertson dwarit making this the
first star trek film to be penned by
women star trek 4 is set to hit theaters
on december 22nd 2023
although rumor has it that a third
sherlock holmes film has always been
part of the warner brothers plan things
have been a little slow recently since
robert downey jr has spent the past
decade anchoring the marvel cinematic
universe saving the world every couple
years is a draining gig and downey's
superhero commitments kept him from
being able to take on the detective role
for a third time
now that downey has finally exited the
mcu for good however he finally has the
time to team up with jude laws watson
for one more case the third sherlock
holmes film will be held by rocketman
director dexter fletcher a departure
from the first two films which were both
directed by guy ritchie meanwhile the
script comes from narcos creator chris
brancato while sherlock holmes 3 was
originally scheduled to release on
christmas day 2020 it's since been
delayed due to the uncertainty caused by
the kova 19 pandemic after having its
theatrical release bumped from 2020 to
december 21 2021 fletcher remarked in
the fall of 2020 that the sequel is
sitting in limbo until things get back
on track while the film obviously won't
make its christmas 2021 release at the
moment it's suspected that sherlock
holmes 3 will hit theaters sometime in
2022
disney's live action reimaginings of
their animated classics have proven to
be a home run at the box office and the
live action aladdin was no exception
bringing in over 1 billion dollars
globally so it comes at no surprise that
it's getting a follow-up although this
one likely won't be modeled directly off
the animated version of the animated
sequel few details are known about the
aladdin sequel although stars will smith
mina masood and naomi scott are all
expected to reprise their respective
roles as genie aladdin and jasmine guy
richie is also expected to return to the
director's chair working off a script
from john gattons and andrea burloff as
for the plot it's still very much an
unknown although it's possible that the
sequel could take the form of an
adaptation of another folk tale from
1001 nights aside from that though
everyone's still very much in the dark
on this one
before bad boys for life had even hit
theaters in early 2020 sony was already
prepping the fourth installment of the
bad boys franchise bad boys 4 was
announced in january 2020 as a follow-up
to the first three films in the hit
buddy cop action franchise which first
kicked off in 1995 with the original bad
boys starring will smith and martin
lawrence that original movie follows two
miami detectives as they investigate a
case of stolen heroine while protecting
the witness to a murder bad boys was
successful enough to earn a sequel which
was released in 2003 the third movie bad
boys for life catches up with detectives
lowry and burnett 17 years later as they
investigate a string of murders with
connections to lowry's past bad boys bad
boys what's she gonna do
what's she gonna do hey hey hey uh-uh no
no
never
no plot details have yet been revealed
about the fourth film but the script is
being penned by chris bremner who also
worked on bad boys for life while
nothing is official yet it's also safe
to assume that smith and lawrence will
both return for part four here's hoping
it doesn't take another 17 years to
release
despite having a pretty definitive
ending the oscar-nominated queen flick
bohemian rhapsody may be getting a
sequel the first film portrays the early
days of the iconic group from its
unsteady beginnings in 1970 when farooq
bolsara first joined through the next
few decades as bolsaro changes his name
to freddie mercury rises to fame and
eventually splits up the group in the
early 80s bohemian rap city ends with
the band reuniting for queen's
performance at live aid in 1985 before
explaining how mercury died of aids in
1991. there's no word yet on what the
plot of bohemian rhapsody 2 could be
whether it would delve into the last six
years of mercury's life or whether it
would follow the other members of the
band after his death in a post on
instagram live in 2021 queen guitarist
brian may said it's going to be hard to
follow bohemian rap city as none of us
could have predicted how massive that
was going to be but yes we are thinking
maybe it could happen but it would have
to be a great script it's going to take
a while to figure that out but as far as
whether the band has interest in a
sequel may said we are looking at it
yeah we have been looking at ideas
while 2021's cruella was set up to serve
as a prequel to disney's animated film
101 dalmatians by the time the end
credits rolled it was clear that there
was plenty more of cruella's story to
tell sure enough cruella 2 is now in the
works which will see emma stone
returning to the role of estella and her
ruthless alter ego cruella deville also
coming back as director craig gillespie
and writer tony mcnamara although none
of stone's fellow cruella cast members
are yet confirmed for the sequel the
first film saw aspiring fashion designer
and petty criminal estella scheming her
way to the top of the fashion industry
and usurping the reign of reigning
fashion queen baroness von hellman by
the end of the film cruella has claimed
the baroness's empire as her own and
fully embraced her dark and
semi-villainous persona yet she still
has a great love of dogs particularly
dalmatians which begs the question of
just how she transforms into the kind of
person who wants to skin them for her
coats perhaps we'll find out when
cruella 2 eventually struts into
theaters
producer and director phil lord has said
that the team behind the jump street
movies is putting a pin in 23 jump
street which would mark the third outing
for channing tatum and jonah hill
however the studio is moving forward
with a spin-off of the comedy franchise
this time focusing on a female crime
fighting duo the first two jump street
films follow a pair of male cops who go
undercover at educational institutions
in order to ferret out elusive drug
suppliers presumably the plot of jump
street now for her pleasure would be
much in the same vein it will also
probably exist in the same universe as
the existing jump street films
functioning as a continuation of the
story started by officers morton schmidt
and greg jenko in the first movies this
time the stars taking the fight to the
streets will be tiffany haddish and
zendaya who will most likely be playing
undercover narcotics officers similar to
tatum and hill's characters in the first
two movies after directing the first two
jump street films chris miller and phil
lord will be stepping aside for this
third outing with rodney rothman taking
the director's chair rosman will also be
collaborating on the script with bob's
burgers writers lizzie and wendy
molyneux rothman previously helped write
the screenplay for 22 jump street and
co-directed lord and miller's acclaimed
animated film spider-man into the
spider-verse sadly there's been no word
yet on what the plot will entail or
whether schmidt or jenko might make an
appearance
sylvester stallone and the expendables 4
have been engaging in a will they won't
they dance for a few years now but it's
finally official the muscle-bound gang
is getting back together again with
scott wah directing and spencer cohen
writing the script in addition to
stallone the expendables franchise has
been a veritable who's who of current
and former action superstars featuring
everyone from mel gibson to bruce willis
to jean-claude van damme to chuck norris
and many many many more
i'm back
this time around we know that stallone
and jason statham are coming back as are
dolph lundgren and ufc legend randy
couture a number of other stars
including megan fox and 50 cent have
also signed on to the film in
undisclosed roles plus the former holder
of the world's strongest man title eddie
hall has personally been offered a role
by stallone himself paul will play a
villain as will martial art star
ekoaways who will apparently be facing
off against statham's character in the
film of course these are still the early
days for the project so don't be
surprised to see more expendables
veterans return and a few other fresh
faces too
after the massive commercial success of
disney's photo realistic remake of the
lion king it seemed like only a matter
of time until a sequel was announced
however the director taking the
directorial reigns from john favreau for
the lion king 2 is probably not a name
most people would have expected to hear
barry jenkins this academy award-winning
writer and director is best known for
creating critically acclaimed dramas
with strong racial themes including
moonlight and if beale street could talk
jenkins won't be writing the lion king 2
but he'll be working from a script by
jeff nathanson who also penned the first
lion king while no specific details of
the plot have been revealed we know that
it will act as a prequel to the first
film following mufasa and scar in their
younger years it will also introduce a
number of new characters though who they
are and what animals they might be has
yet to be confirmed although the lion
king 2 seems like an outlier in jenkins
filmography the director sounds excited
about working on the sequel for disney
saying having the opportunity to work
with disney on expanding this
magnificent tale of friendship love and
legacy while furthering my work
chronicling the lives and souls of folk
within the african diaspora is a dream
come true
some films get theatrical or streaming
sequels while others get turned into tv
series but if you're the nicholas cage
series national treasure you get both
the long-awaited three cool to 2004's
national treasure and 2007's national
treasure book of secrets seems to
finally be moving forward at disney
tapping bad boy's forescribe chris
brumner to write the script but that's
not all national treasure will also find
new life as a disney plus tv series
which producer jerry bruckheimer says is
currently in the development process
while national treasure 3 is expected to
reunite the cast from the first two
films including cage himself the tv
series will follow a young woman named
jessie who embarks on an adventure to
uncover a lost pan-american treasure
serving as one of the executive
producers for the series is john
turtletown who helmed both of the first
two films and is expected to direct the
third although the disney plus series is
currently further along in the
development pipeline with production set
to start in early 2022 bruck armor says
he's hopeful that both projects will
ultimately come to fruition delivering a
veritable treasure trove of new national
treasure adventures
with the open-ended conclusion of the
2020 charlize theron action hit the old
guard it seemed as though the film was
begging for a sequel sure enough the old
guard 2 is in the works for netflix the
sequel will bring back star charlize
theron as andy the millennia-old
mercenary who in the first film realized
her immortality was finally beginning to
wane also returning will be marwan
kanzari and luca marinelli who played
joe nicky respectively the life partners
for centuries who also act as part of
andy's group production is set to start
in the first quarter of 2022 with
victoria mahoney attached to direct and
while no plot details have been released
yet the first film set up some
intriguing possibilities after betraying
the other members of their group and
being punished with a century of exile
the devious booker comes face to face
with quinn played by veronica no quinn
is a former member of their immortal
squad who they had thought was lost
forever at the bottom of the ocean i
feel her pain
her rage
she feels crazy
although quinn used to be andy's closest
ally centuries of drowning over and over
might just have changed her tune this
intriguing story thread will hopefully
be followed up when the old guard 2 hits
netflix sometime in the future
mere days after the 2021 chris pratt's
sci-fi action film the tomorrow award
dropped on amazon prime amazon studios
and skydance were already talking about
a sequel the first film centers around
pratt's character who's recruited as a
soldier to travel to the future and
fight war to save humanity the sequel
would reportedly bring back pratt and
the first movie's main cast along with
director chris mckay and writer zach
dean the tomorrow war earned an
enthusiastic reaction from amazon prime
subscribers who viewed it enough for it
to debut as the number one film across
streaming platforms over the july 4th
holiday weekend so it's no wonder that
the studios would be eagerly circling a
sequel although no specific plans are
confirmed yet and while we don't yet
know what the story of a potential the
tomorrow war ii would be it will
hopefully be just as thrilling and
action-packed as the first film
the long-running insidious franchise is
getting a fifth installment and this
time franchise star patrick wilson will
be settling into the director's chair
the first two films follow a couple
whose young son is haunted by
otherworldly beings while the third and
fourth are prequels that focus on the
psychic who aided the heroes of the
first two films insidious five will
follow the sun from the original movie
now a decade older as he heads off to
college in a statement regarding his
directorial duties on the fifth movie
wilson said i'm honored and thrilled to
be at the helm of the next insidious
installment which will provide an
amazing chance to unpack everything the
lamberts went through a decade ago as
well as deal with the consequences of
their choices into the further we go the
further that wilson is referring to is
the demonic realm that houses the
entities which haunt the characters in
the insidious films the script for
insidious five was penned by scott teams
and based on a story by lee winnell who
wrote the first four films in the
franchise
although the original tron wasn't much
of a hit when it was released in 1982
the movie developed a growing cult
following in the decades that followed
which ultimately proved big enough to
warrant a sequel tron legacy premiered
in 2010 starring garrett headland olivia
wilde and original tron star jeff
bridges tron legacy did well enough to
earn a sequel of its own and it runs in
the family writer jesse wigatau was
brought aboard in 2012 to pen the script
however disney reportedly couldn't
figure out how to best approach a new
installment in the tron series and so
the project was put on hold now the
third tron film appears to be moving
forward again with lion director garth
davis coming aboard to direct and jared
leto attached to star while davis is not
known for the type of big-budget
cgi-heavy filmmaking that a tron film
would require insiders say that he
fought hard for the job eventually
convincing disney executives that he was
the right person to bring the grid back
to life as for leto he may have
inadvertently revealed the title for the
third tron film in a now deleted tweet
confirming his casting referring to the
film as tron aries although the project
has yet to receive a green light davis
and leto's involvement may signal a
light at the end of the tunnel for this
long gestating three-quarter check out
one of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos about your
favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]